what role do you think luck plays in
poker and in life you can pick whichever
one you want poker or life and or life
the longer you play
the less influenced luck has you know
like with all things the bigger your
sample size
um the more the quality of your
decisions or your strategies matter
um so to answer that question yeah in
poker it really depends if you and I sat
and played 10 hands right now I might
only win 52 of the time 53 maybe
um but if we played ten thousand hands
then I'll probably win like over 98 99
of the time so it's a question of sample
sizes and what are you figuring out over
time the betting strategy that this
individual does or it literally doesn't
matter against any individual over time
against any individual over time the
better player because they're making
better decisions so what does that mean
to make a better decision well ah to get
into the real Integrity already
um basically poker is the game of math
um there are these strategies familiar
with like Nash equilibria that's us
right so there are these Game Theory
optimal strategies that you can adopt
um and the closer you play to them the
less exploitable you are so
because I've studied the game a bunch
um although admittedly not for a few
years but back in you know when I was
playing all the time
um I would study these Game Theory
Optimal Solutions and try and then adopt
those strategies when I go and play so
I'd play against you and I would do that
and
because
the objective when you're playing game
theory optimal it's actually it's a loss
minimization thing that you're trying to
do
um your best bet is to try and play uh
the sort of similar style you also need
to try and adopt this lost minimization
um but because I've been playing much
longer than you I'll be better at that
so first of all you're not taking
advantage of my mistakes but then on top
of that
I'll be better at recognizing when you
are playing sub-optimally and then
deviating from this game theory optimal
strategy to exploit your bad plays
can you define game theory and Nash
equilibria can we try to sneak up to it
in a bunch of ways like oh what's a game
theory framework of analyzing poker
analyzing any kind of situation so game
theory is just basically the
study of
decisions within a competitive situation
um I mean statically a branch of
Economics
um but it also applies to like wider
decision Theory
um and
you know usually when you see it it's
these like little payoff matrices and so
on that's how it's depicted but it's
essentially just like study of
strategies under different competitive
situations
um and as it happens certain games in
fact many many games
um have these things called Nash
equilibria and what that means is when
you're in a Nash equilibrium basically
uh it is not there is no strategy that
you can take that would be more
beneficial than the one you're currently
taking assuming your opponent is also
doing the same thing
um so it'd be a bad idea you know if
we're both playing a in you know a game
three optimal strategy if either of us
deviate from that now the other you know
the we're putting ourselves at a
disadvantage
um rock paper scissors is actually a
really great example of this like if we
to were to start playing rock paper you
know you know nothing about me and we're
gonna play for all our money let's play
10 rounds of it what would your sort of
optimal strategy be do you think what
would you do
um
let's see
I would
probably try to be as random as possible
exactly you want to because you don't
know anything about me you don't want to
give anything about away about yourself
so ideally you'd have like a little dice
or somewhat you know perfect randomizer
that makes you randomize 33 of the time
each of the three different things and
in response to that
um well actually I can kind of do
anything but I would probably just
randomize back too but actually it
wouldn't matter because you'll I know
that you're playing randomly
um so that would be us in a Nash
equilibrium um where we're both playing
this like unexplosable strategy
however if after a while you then notice
that I'm playing rock a little bit more
often than I should yeah you're the kind
of person that would do that wouldn't
you sure yes yes no I'm more of a
scissors girl but anyway you are uh no
I'm a as I said randomizer uh so you
notice I'm throwing Rock too much or
something like that right now you'd be
making a mistake by continuing playing
this game theory optimal strategy
because well the previous one because
you are now there's a I'm making a
mistake and you're not deviating and
exploiting my mistake
um so you'd want to start throwing paper
a bit more often
um in whatever you figure is the right
sort of percentage of the time that I'm
throwing Rock too often so that's
basically an example of where you know
what what game three optimal strategy is
in terms of loss minimization but it's
not always uh the maximally profitable
thing if your opponent is doing stupid
stupid stuff which you know in that
example so that's kind of then how it
works in poker but it's a lot more
complex
um and the way poker players typically
you know nowadays they study the games
change so much and I think we should
talk about how it sort of evolved
um but nowadays like the top Pros
basically spend all their time in
between sessions running these
simulators uh using like software where
they do basically Monte Carlo
simulations sort of doing billions of
fictitious self-play hands
you input a fictitious hand scenario
like oh what do I do with Jack nine
suited on a King 10 4 to 2 Spade board
um uh and and you know against this bet
size so you'd input that press play
it'll run it's it's uh you know it's
billions of fake hands and then it will
converge upon what the game theory
optimal strategies are
um and then you want to try and memorize
what these are basically they're like
ratios of how often you know what types
of hands uh you want to Bluff and what
percentage of the time so then there's
this additional layer of inbuilt
randomization built in yeah those kind
of simulations incorporate all the
betting strategies and everything else
like that so they so as opposed to some
kind of very crude mathematical model of
what's the probability you went just
based on the quality of the card uh it's
including everything else too the game
theory of it yes yeah essentially and
what's interesting is that nowadays if
you want to be a top Pro and you go and
play in these really like the super high
stakes tournaments or tough cash games
if you don't know this stuff you're
going to get eaten alive in the long run
yeah but of course you could get lucky
over the short run and that's where this
like luck Factor comes in because luck
is both a blessing and a curse if luck
didn't you know if there wasn't this
random element and there wasn't the
ability For Worse players to win
sometimes then poker would fall apart
you know the same reason people don't
play chess uh professionally for money
against you you don't see people going
and hustling uh chess like not knowing
uh trying to make a living from it
because you know there's very little
luck in chess but there's quite a lot of
luck in poker